قلت صحيفه بوليتيكو ان اوكرانيا ستتسلم
منتصف شهر سبتمبر الجاري اول عشر دبابات
من اصل احدى و30 دبابه امريكيه من طراز
اضافت الصحيفه ان ذلك ياتي بعد ان انهى
مائه عسكريا اوكراني تجربات على قياده
واستخدام هذا النوع من الدبابات الثقيله
في قاعده عسكريه في المانيا واوضحت
الصحيفه ان الفرق الاوكرانيه المعنيه باتت
جاهزه للتعامل مع دبابات ابرمز في ساحات
المعارك
قال الرئيس الاوكراني
قال ان تركيزه والمسؤولين الحكوميين
والعسكريين ينصبوا على الخطوط الاماميه
والعمليات الهجوميه اضاف في كلمه له ان
مدى الاسلحه الاوكرانيه يبلغ 700 كم حاليا
وان القياده الاوكرانيه تسعى لزياده مدى
الاسلحه الهجوميه كشف زينسكي عن ارسال عدد
اكبر من مركبات الاخلاء الطبي الى الجبهات
الاماميه
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي نرحب بك طبعا
العميد الياس حنا ونتوقف عندما قاله
فولو من ان الاسلحه الاوكرانيه بلغ مداها
700 كيلومتر وهناك محاولات ايضا لتطوير
هذا المدى دلالات ذلك وتبعته على ارتفاع
ازدهار اظهر الاوكرانيون يعني
ابتكارا مهما يعني على سبيل المثال هم
ماهرون في الصناعات الثقيله يعني هم
يصنعون محركات طائرات
للمسيرات بيردار هم ايضا يعدلون الاسلحه
القديمه يعني هم بين الموجه الصناعيه
والموجه التكنولوجيه الحديثه 350 الف
مهندس
او انفرميشن تكنولوجي باوكرانيا زادت
زاد التصدير بالاي تي سيرفيس الخدمات
بالمعلومات او التكنولوجيا بالعام 22 الى
7.46 مليار دولار فاذا اليوم نحن نقول عن
قاعده علميه موجوده الصناعات العسكريه
اليوم اذا استطاعت ان تتخلى عن الضغوطات
الغربيه هذا الامر يعني ان هناك حريه عمل
تقنيه
واستراتيجيه لضرب اهداف داخل روسيه على
سبيل المثال
المسيره
المعدله مداها الف كيلو متر هي من صنع
السوفيتي قديم ولكنها معدله صاروخ
النيبتون ارض بحر عد الى اليوم لضرب اهداف
داخل القرن فاذا صناعه محليه مدى بعيد هذا
امر يعني حريه عملانيه وخيارات استراتيجيه
تدريب الكوادر ايضا كما يتعلق بالطياريين
في الاف سته عشر او
المقاتلين على بعض الدبابات ومنها ابرز
الابرز شيء مهم جدا يجب ان ننتظر لنرى
العدد العدد 41 الاستلام قليل اليوم يجب
التدريب التمرين ومن ذلك وبالتالي ادخالها
في المنظومه العسكريه في المنظومه التي
تقاتل يعني لا يمكن ادخال دبابه مع مقاتل
مع كتيبه من الدبابات جديده مباشره في ارض
معركه له وقت منذ ثلاثه اشهر يعني الهجوم
المضاد اليوم الجيش الاوكراني يحقق في
روبوتين بعض التقدم ولكن ما ياتي لاحقا هو
سيكون دعم واحتياط استراتيج عملاني مهم
جدا جدا في حال حصل هذا الخرق العميد
الياس حنا بجوار كل ذلك هنالك حرب مسيرات
ومسيرات تصل الى كل مكان ومن هذه الاماكن
مقاطعه موسكو يعني ما خطوره ذلك ونحن
نستمع الى عمده موسكو يتحدث عن اجراءات
يجب اتخاذها لتوسيع نطاق الدفاع
محمد المسيره يمكن تعديلها
لتتوائم مع الوضع العملي والاستراتيجي
ولكن الدفاعات الجويه القديمه تستلزم
تكنولوجيا جديده وقت اطول للتاقلم وهذا ما
يميز المسيرات الاوكرانيه الصناعات صناعه
محليه على سبيل المثال الواشنطن بوست نشرت
مقالا مطولا تقول ان هناك 200 شركه تصنع
المسيرات تستعمل بعضها الزكاه الاصطناعي
ما المقصود بالذكاء الاصطناعي في حال تم
التشويش عليها بالحرب الالكترونيه يكون
لدى هذه المسيره باستعمال الذكاء
الاصطناعي والذهاب مباشره دون اي توجيه
الى هدفها فاذا نحن امام مرحله جديده
والاهم بالامر محمد انك تصمم هذه المسيره
تجربها في ارض المعركه وتاتي بالدروس
المستقاط مباشره الى المختبرات لتعديلها
وهذا امر نادر في الحروب
عميد الياس حناء الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي من بيروت شكرا الينا